that is liable for years these activists
representing families killed and injured
in libya have been coming to this u.s
courthouse trying to convince a judge
that khalifa haftar should be held
civilly liable for what his forces have
done in libya and on friday the judge
agreed saying he is financially
responsible for torture and
extrajudicial killings
haftar didn't testify in his own defense
but those suing described indiscriminate
crimes against civilians including the
bombing of a hospital they bombed it and
when this
this libyan
person he attempted to run into the
building and save people from the
building and he was hit by another
another bomb that was shelled over the
hospital and he ended up dying
you know these are the common folks
though suing also hope this impacts his
political future in libya the message
that is being sent is that how can you
allow a criminal who has committed
egregious crimes and who is being held
responsible in front a fair
court
you know for his crimes how can you even
have the the notion that this man can
stand in an election haftar has not been
convicted of a crime but the lawyers
hope it will still be costly it's
rumored he has
hundreds of millions of dollars perhaps
more around the world up next the judge
will decide what he'll pay for what
she's now said he's done then they'll
begin the difficult task of trying to
find his assets and seize them
patty culhane al jazeera alexandria
virginia